if you're a guy who can score a 150 on
an IQ test but you live in a basement
and all you do is yell about how
unfortunate you are all day actually you
are not very smart in an important way
you could take good multiple choice
questions but something has gone wrong
in your life and you've been unable to
unravel that and that's what happened to
that one guy who sometimes goes as like
the smartest man in the world it just
seems like the smartest man in the world
should be able to like get a bank loan
dude I love your sub stack your sub
stack was one of my favorite finds
throughout all of last year it's
absolutely phenomenal I appreciate that
it's very kind of you to say
congratulations man what's your
background who are you what do you do
um I'm trained as a psychologist in
social psychology so the kind of
psychology that I can't help people
directly but I can certainly write
papers about them uh so that's what I
got my PhD in a couple years ago uh
right now
um I'm like finishing up a job where I
teach uh negotiation to business
students uh but mainly what I do is
write that sub stack
you made the decision to go full time or
more serious part way through last year
yeah yeah uh yeah basically I got tired
of writing papers that nobody reads
where you basically have to lie to get
them published and I thought why not
just write what really happened in my
studies uh or what's really going on in
my head uh on the internet and I thought
maybe nobody would listen and then
people started listening uh and then
they started shouting at me and that's
another story what what was that thing
that you pirated you pirated a study did
it yourself and just published it and
said sort of stuck a middle finger up at
the usual Journal submission process
yeah I was running these studies with a
friend of mine on basically what happens
when you ask people how things could be
different and you know they write out
their answers and we're like okay if it
was different in that way how much
better or worse would it be uh and it
would tell us and and so we had like
eight studies investigating this
question of this this bias in human
imagination and we were writing trying
to write it up for a scientific journal
and we felt like we couldn't do it
without lying like things like we forgot
why we ran study eight this happened
sometimes you're working on a bunch of
projects you look back like wait why did
we do that like the results are
interesting but now I can't reconstruct
how we got to the point where we ran
study eight and I was like Ethan my
co-author is like what should we do and
we were like what if we just told the
truth uh and just like wrote it
ourselves and put it on the internet and
so we're like hey guys here's study
eight we don't remember why we ran it if
you can figure it out why don't you
write to us and people really did which
is the best part
um so yeah so we just wrote it honestly
and put it on the internet which is uh
the way I intend to do science going
forward and you got shouted at by people
on the internet twice
yeah a little bit yeah uh so not so much
for that people seem to be cool I know
some people are like science it's very
serious and there shouldn't be jokes and
I'm like man who killed your fun uh but
then I wrote an article about peer
review which is this process that
scientific papers are supposed to
undergo before they're published
um and basically why it's a failed
experiment
um and I had someone in the comments
being like uh Adam do you still work at
UH at this this dorm I used to work at
when I was in in Graduate School uh like
I have serious doubts about your ability
to Mentor undergraduates like this is
very serious I'm a Harvard Alum which is
where that dorm was that I worked
um and this person was a tenured
professor at Boston University I was
like man so people got nothing better to
do than uh than yell at random people on
the internet
um fortunately she was a little I don't
work there anymore
um you got accused of cynical
metacognitive Polly waffle yeah yeah
does that describe do you think that
describes your approach accurately uh
yes it describes it to a point
um yeah some people
Julie Matt especially when you uh
criticize the the ladders basically that
they've climbed up
um and when you go hey it seems like
these systems don't actually do the
things that people claim that they do
they go uh yes they do and also you're a
big meanie well I mean if you've spent
most of your career playing the rules of
a game and somebody else comes and says
as if we ever considered whether we
could just change these rules because
they kind of seem a little bit dumb
quite rightly people are going to seem
pretty threatened but the bottom line is
it doesn't seem like a particularly
effective way to play the game at least
given the outcomes that they are
purported to be trying to get
yeah exactly that uh that if it's so
good for papers to undergo this process
that we call peer review then you should
be able to like tell the difference
between the papers the two of the papers
that don't you should be able to see
like oh yeah reviewers actually catch
big errors and they don't uh you should
hear lots of stories of like yeah man
this guy tried to submit a paper to a
journal and the reviewers like caught on
that he was faking his data and now he
got fired you never hear a story like
that those stories always begin with
yeah this guy published 60 papers 60
peer-reviewed papers and journals and
then someone was like wait should we
check the data and then they did and it
turned out was all made up and then the
guy got fired uh and so when you have a
system that works like that but it takes
000 person years of Labor every year uh
to make it go maybe that's a system that
like I don't know maybe we should try to
think about other things I'm not even
saying everybody should do what I did
this is what works for me
um like I like writing papers in my own
voice and giving them direct to people
some people like this system great they
should do it but they shouldn't for
Force other people at gunpoint to do it
as well why aren't smart people happier
uh uh I think it was because our uh
definition of intelligence and the way
that we test it carves off one part of
what a human mind can do and then
basically claims that that is everything
that a human mind can do so when you
take an intelligence test you're
basically taking a standardized as a
bunch of multiple choice questions
um and and it turns out that like your
ability to take those questions actually
does matter so a lot of people want to
pretend that like oh we're not measuring
anything that we really do like it this
is related to some of your life outcomes
your your ability to to get and to hold
certain jobs but what it turns out to
not be related to it is no correlation
with uh how satisfied you say you are
with your life
um which is of course a key problem that
people are trying to solve and so it
suggests that like your ability to like
do those anagrams and like solve these
logic problems and do reading
comprehension questions is unrelated to
your ability to like make choices in
your life that when you look back you go
oh those are the right choices I feel
good about those choices that I made and
I think a great example of this is like
there are people who score extremely
high on IQ tests who make extremely
stupid decisions uh I mean every year
you hear about professors you know are
like oh man they like couldn't keep
their hands to themselves and they
sexually harassed a bunch of people and
now they're fired that just seems like
that I mean an immoral thing to do but
also a really dumb thing to do and so
you think if these people uh can Ace
these tests that they would also be able
to not make very stupid obvious mistakes
wasn't so that's why I think there was
some guy that you looked at who was
adamant that Banks weren't giving him
bank account because he was white and
then Bobby Fischer this sort of Chess
Prodigy just started going on about the
Jews again you know you can argue over
the veracity of their argument the point
is if you're a Super Genius investment
advisor to somebody or the number one
chess Prodigy in the world
don't talk about the Jews if you want to
keep your job and be surprised yeah yeah
if you're a guy who can you know score a
150 on an IQ test but you live in a
basement and all you do is yell about
how unfortunate you are all day it just
seems to be like actually you are not
very smart in an important way like you
could take good multiple choice
questions but something has gone wrong
in your life and you've been unable to
unravel that uh and that's what happened
to that one guy who's who sometimes goes
as like the smartest man in the world
um it just seems like the smartest man
in the world should be able to like get
a bank loan
um which is a thing that people do every
day uh they don't have to be a genius to
do it you just gotta like have some good
credit and like explain what you want
for it uh but like this guy can't do it
does that mean that smart people are
more miserable or is there no
correlation between intelligence and
happiness yeah no correlation so this
has been found across study they did
some of this analysis myself
um it seems like there's either no
correlation or a very tiny one uh that
can easily go in either direction so
it's also not that like oh have like
having all this brain power makes you
less happy it just seems to be that
there are these these problems in life
that are different from the ones that we
test when we test people's intelligence
what are the wrong theories that smart
people have about what's going to make
them happy in life
uh I think it is oh I'll just get like
this really prestigious job and I'll
just make lots of money and then like
question mark question mark question
mark I'll be content and feel good about
myself
um and I mean all you need to do is look
around uh and like actually get to know
some of the people who have accomplished
those things uh and quite often they
feel like oh well no there's this other
thing I just need to do and like then
I'll be happy
um and and most often I mean the people
like the best predictor that we have of
happiness is the quality of your Social
relationships
um and uh and it turns out that like
yeah those can sometimes suffer if the
thing that you are maximizing is uh the
title of your job or the size of your
bank account
I wonder whether smart people get
captured or caught up in those sorts of
games more readily than people who are
less smart perhaps they have more
opportunities and always that are open
to them or something like that
yeah it's easy to like see the game
being played and get really good at
playing the game because if you're good
at acing these tests you're probably
good at game playing and then a mistake
playing the game for living a meaningful
and satisfying life uh that you know you
could spend your whole life doing it and
just be like ah but if I could just do
better at the game if I could just
acquire more Monopoly money uh then like
at some point I start feeling good uh
and the thing about Monopoly buddy is
it's fake there is no amount that you
could have before you feel good
there was a quote from a friend who I I
really reflected on a lot last year and
I realized that we trade the thing that
we want which is time for the thing
which is supposed to get it money we
also trade the thing which we want which
is happiness for the thing which is
supposed to get it success we give up
time to make money so that we can
finally have more time when we have
enough money we give up happiness to
achieve success so that we can finally
have more happiness when we achieve
enough success like it's so what's that
Japanese fisherman proverb thing about
the American businessman that goes to
the Japanese fisherman and says you
could make a fish market and build this
big business up and then eventually
you'd just be able to fish on the on the
lake all day and it does feel a lot of
the time especially now man because my
background's in the productivity world
at least when I started this show and
coming out of that does make me think
that so much over optimization has led
people to get themselves into a
situation where this treadmill this ever
speeding up treadmill of success to
beget happiness which doesn't because
the sacrifice of happiness is in the
achievement of the success for the
happiness yeah it's very self-defeating
yeah uh it's weird that it is so hard
that it is so self-defeating in that way
you'd think that it's all be very
obvious it's just like I know the things
that make me feel good and I should just
do more of those things and not make me
feel good in in like the most basic way
I mean some of those things but make me
feel good in like that deep like
meaningful way that I like but instead
we have extremely strong theories about
what will do that for us that's somehow
seemed like very hard to disconfirm
they're just like ah just a little bit
more and then I'll have it I mean I feel
this in my own life that um it can be
hard to actually tell what you like
doing if you have a very strong theory
about what you should like doing so when
I was writing those scientific papers I
was like yeah no I I like this like this
is good and um and before I start doing
it I just need to like drink a lot of
caffeine hit a Pomodoro Timer like turn
off my phone like turn off the internet
uh and then like make myself do it for
25 minutes and only then can I take a
break and I was like wait that why would
I have to do all these things for a
thing that I supposedly like doing the
things I like doing I just do them and I
don't want to stop and I don't need to
be managed into doing them and so
there's something I think very weird and
unexplained here about how very strong
theories of Happiness can mislead you
into spending a lot of time making
yourself unhappy that's a really
interesting point a very profound point
I think actually where
much of what we take pleasure from it's
very difficult to
separate out in the liquid how much of
this is self-generated stuff that I love
and enjoy and how much of this is
social norms biological predisposition
path of least resistance way that I've
dealt with past trauma you know pick
your filter that you're making your
behavior occur through uh
filling my sense of insufficiency for
today compensating for my sense of
insufficiency that lags over from
yesterday whatever it might be
um yeah so many so many things that we
do are
compensatory in that regard yeah yeah
uh yeah and it's it's weird how you
could spend a lot of time like hanging
out with friends that you don't really
like uh like working hard to like be
promoted at a job that you don't really
enjoy
um and I think it really takes paying
very close attention to your experiences
to be like wait what do I actually feel
like when I'm doing these things
um and if it's not good like why am I
fighting so hard to continue to do them
um I used to have this conversation a
lot when I was uh like a resident
advisor in an undergrad in graduate
school so I talked to students a lot
about like what they like to do and uh
and often it was really hard for them
because they had gotten to like these
Elite educational institutions in part
by tamping down on the part of
themselves that like enjoyed doing
things for the sake of doing them and
instead of being really good at it at
like convincing themselves that they
enjoyed doing the things that got them
rewards and got them admission into
Princeton and Harvard and places like
that
um and it was really sad to watch it
because it's like they had lost the
ability to like feel true pleasure uh
and were just like I enjoy doing the
things that like increased my CV I'm
like man you don't and like you're
that's gonna collapse it on itself
eventually what is a smarter way for
smart people to become happy then
uh I think it is paying that close
attention to like when I feel that sense
that thing that I like to feel uh it's
not just purely the pleasure of like you
know I took a look at ice cream it is
the pleasure of I feel fulfilled I feel
meaningful like what is it you're doing
when you're doing that uh because
everybody feels that at some point
um and maybe in those times you haven't
given yourself the permission to feel
that way
um because the thing that you're doing
isn't something that's prestigious
enough or you think it doesn't pay
enough I have a friend of mine who
literally what he would love to do is uh
Campground maintenance this guy once who
dig ditches hang hammocks like he wants
two men defenses
um and he knows he likes doing it and
like he likes to work on his house and
instead like he's a uh um like a
computer engineer um because like that
pays more he doesn't really like doing
it I just want to take him aside and be
like dude this is a job that people have
like you can make money like you not as
much money but just think of all the
hours of your life you're going to spend
doing the thing that you don't like to
to like dig dig ditches in your yeah
[Music]
um I have a friend a friend who's got an
unbelievably successful YouTube channel
millions and millions of of subscribers
huge business off the back of it and he
spends all of his time in a really nice
apartment out in California with a bunch
of his other friends filming
Dungeons and Dragons
role play you know the board game thing
but one of them is a Storyteller and
it's sort of narrated
and this isn't I don't even know if it's
on the internet I think that they just
he's got a good amount of disposable
income I guess but yeah that's what he's
chosen to spend his time doing yeah you
know you're sending through the
troposphere of all of the different
problems you need to in terms of
resource acquisition and then at the age
of 33 retired to be a professional
Dungeons and Dragons master or whatever
it is that he does yeah good for him uh
but yeah a lot of people put in all
those years and don't get to it don't
get that uh retirement at the end or it
comes much later yes uh yeah
speaking of the world of productivity
it's like I say a world that I was very
familiar with for a long time what is
your issue with eating frogs
yeah so I wrote this post uh about this
idea like there's this productivity
system called like eat that frog or
whatever basically the thing you want to
do the least to do that first
um which that in itself is not crazy
whatever we've all had to do stuff that
we don't want to do if you do it
immediately you know you cut down on the
time that you spend dreading doing it I
think that's not the problem I think the
problem is feeling like there is
something Noble and natural in spending
a lot of time eating frogs or eating a
lot of them
um anything that comes from this theory
that we have about the way that we are
naturally which is that people feel like
oh deep down I'm actually a lazy piece
of garbage like if left to my own
devices I will sit motionless and watch
Netflix and play video I will do all of
these things that like uh are not
actually good
um and only by like whipping my
unconscious self like my natural self
into shape will I like become this
person who does the things that are
productive and good I think that
actually comes from a lifetime of having
to force yourself to do those things and
then convince yourself that is the good
self
um I think it's wrong I think actually
like our unconscious elves uh uh are
pretty smart I think they uh they tend
to be pretty well attuned to like things
that are valuable and it only feels like
our natural incoming shootings are
toward laziness because uh our
unconscious self only alerts our
conscious self like when there's some
kind of issue like when something needs
to be done uh and so I have this
metaphor in the in the piece of like if
you hire an intern and tell that intern
like hey just go do the tasks and then
just like come to me if you ever have a
problem whenever they if you just ignore
them when they're doing the tasks but
pay attention to them when they have the
problem you will assume that like man
this interior doesn't do anything they
just come to me all the time not paying
attention to all the stuff that internet
is doing when you're not looking and
that is what your unconscious self is
doing
um and so I think you can get this
totally wrong theory about what you
would do when you were left to do
whatever you want to do
um based on like the wrong uh impression
of how your unconscious self works why
do you think it is that we have this
Puritan self-flagellation
like secret autoerotica thing going on
part of it I I think not to be too
conspiratorial but I think this works
really well for the people who are
trying to squeeze labor out of us on
board for this I'm absolutely on board
for hating yourself and feeling like the
only way to subvert feelings of
insufficiency are to contribute to a
capitalist machine I'm on board with
this conspiracy yeah so uh if your boss
could convince you that like yeah the
things that you like to do are actually
like lazy and bad like it's bad to play
video games it's bad to read books it's
good to do spreadsheets and emails uh
and like only when you're doing those is
when you are your true self uh so you
must sublimate and subjugate uh your
like natural self
um I think that's part of where it comes
from uh and so I think we learned over
time to like not give ourselves
permission to actually value and enjoy
those things
um and a lot of it too is like you have
to do some of that to survive uh you you
have to work jobs that pay you money so
that you can do the other things but
it's easy to get confused and be like oh
no actually working the job and paying
the money is the good thing and having
the fun part is like the bad thing like
that's like sneaking a cookie from the
cookie jar that's like having a little
that's a little Indulgence for us like
no that's also life that's also good
like that's not supposed to have that
you you've broken disgusting creature
get yourself back to the desk tie
yourself right there come on do it until
your fingertips bleed you [__]
um I read
that the ancient Greek word for work was
originally translated as not at leisure
so in ancient Greece they saw Leisure as
the set point and work as the aberration
I must have said this five times maybe
more on the podcast then when it did a
bit of digging turns out it's not true
uh so a really really great
just perfect example of of something I
would have loved to use as a metaphor
and now and now I can't but I can
continue I think it's still it still is
very nice thinking about the way that
over time humans have changed their
perspective of work and I mean it's only
been you know you can go back 200 years
to see a very different sort of approach
to work and what it meant that it was a
contribution mostly for survival it was
just you were connected with your work
in a more existential way as opposed to
this kind of like dopamine hamster wheel
thing that it's just for it's for show
as opposed to maybe for the honor of
your family or the pride in your name or
the the value of your cow when you go to
market I don't know you know what I mean
yeah yeah uh yeah some things even if
not uh factually true are emotionally
true so uh uh like that uh that Greek
story but um but no I think this is true
that like if uh if your job can convince
you that like this is actually the way
that you express yourself
um and like this isn't just for money
like this is who you are
um then like you give them a very
powerful tool of controlling your
behavior that it like you allow them to
convince you that like no what you
really like to do uh like when you are
your true conscious and good self like
what you really like to do is like be on
time and you like to go to meetings and
like uh you like to make projects come
in under deadline uh
and yeah I think it'd be much easier if
you showed up and it's like this is a
thing you do for money that is our
relationship that we have
um like you're not here to like attain
self uh uh self-actualization uh we do
hope that you will leave on time and go
do the other things that like this job
allows you to do I think a lot of people
get stuck doing the thing that is next
to the thing that they want to do
confused as to why it doesn't make them
feel good like the thing that they
really like what do you mean next to the
thing
So like
um if you uh if you really if you really
like doing graphic design uh like if you
really like painting um you can get
convinced that like no what you actually
like doing is making logos uh and you
could be like man why doesn't this like
feel good it's because like it's not the
thing it's like slightly to the left or
to the right of the thing that you
really want to do and you might be
better off doing something totally
different uh so you're not confused
about like why this thing that like kind
of looks like the thing that I want to
do doesn't feel good yeah so it's
bleeding over there's a concept from
Stephen pressfields the war of art where
he he calls those Shadow careers he says
the number of people that he met in La
who were failed actors or always wanted
to become an actor but ended up becoming
an agent because it was tangential
enough to the industry that it made them
feel like they were maybe in the thing
but it wasn't the thing and they were
just gonna have this existential
Yearning For the Rest of time
yeah it uh I don't have data to back
this up I just have a deep gut sense
which is honestly like what both
scientists have anyway but this feeling
that like if you actually can't do
exactly the thing that you want to do
you might be better off doing something
that is so different that you don't get
confused as to what is your labor and
what is your pleasure uh it's turning
turning a love into a labor is one of
the quickest ways to be able to destroy
it I've seen so many of my friends that
love to train become a PT launch an
online course teach people how to launch
online courses and then before you know
it they they're you know a million miles
away from being a PT yeah the thing that
they enjoyed was exercise and now what
they do is teach people online who want
to teach people to build a business
online to coach people in the real world
it's even that story of the lady that
started the bakery and wanted to build
it into a business and then five years
later she hasn't baked a cake in yeah
God knows how long and doesn't know
anything that's going on but she's a
great business executive with a very
successful Bakery
it's yeah yeah it we we really do sort
of over complicate things he
numbers is this because of the amount of
degrees of freedom that we have in a
that we've been afforded in the modern
world do you think
yeah I'm sure that's part of it uh part
of it too is being expected to live a
certain life
um you know I mean my my friend who uh
wants to dig ditches and hang hammocks
like people expect him to do a thing you
know he has a college degree
um you look kind of bad if you don't do
the thing that rises to the level that
you're supposed to be educated for
um when in fact like the whole point of
acquiring those additional opportunities
is like to use them to make your life
better uh like this is like the mistake
of spending your whole life like
increasing your bank account and then
you die and you're like ah good I like
died with like a large bank account uh
like I won uh it's like man the money
was for making your life better uh same
two like the degrees are for making your
life better the success is for making
your life better
um not for like uh like increasing the
success meter more
talk to me about Sir Francis Galton
uh this is a guy who lived uh in the
1800s uh the second half of the 1800s
who um was kind of one of the first
modern psychologists
um he did a ton of stuff he invented uh
like nature versus nurture is a a phrase
that he coined
um invented what we now know as
correlation
um weather maps uh the scientific the
scientifically correct way of cutting a
cake was also him arithmetic by smelly
there's like this whole list the first
map of Namibia
um super interesting guy also had some
beliefs that I think now we would find
uh a little distasteful
um but I got to reading his
autobiography and it was just extremely
entertaining and so I wrote a review and
a post about it uh oh also the biggest
thing he invented was Eugenics I
shouldn't have left that off the
grounding achievement yeah
um and so and so I wrote this post
getting it like okay what was this guy's
life like and how did he get to this
point where he made progress in all
these different fields and invented this
thing that he didn't see that uh you
know only about a hundred years later
people would recoil and horror at what
he thought would be a quote permanent
success when he established like the the
chair of eugenics at University College
of London
um and just trying to get it like why is
it so hard to see into the future
morally uh you know he saw into the
future in statistics in biology in
meteorology
um but not in Morality uh and so I was
trying to get to the bottom of that just
to list some more of his achievements
that you put in the article tries to
learn arithmetic by smell succeeds
uh he like trained himself to his
associate numbers of smells and then
like put the smells together and I mean
this is purely his claim but like he
felt the association of like the so you
associate like one smell of three
another smell with uh two you put the
smells together and you feel five
um wow this is a paper in nature like
the premiere well now the premier
um scientific journal worship's a puppet
to see if he can convince himself it has
Godlike Powers succeeds
yeah this too is just a story that he
was like you know some people get
obsessed with like you know cult figures
or whatever like could I understand what
it's like to do that he's like yes I
found this puppet I just started like
worshiping it and he's like yeah I
really came to feel like uh like it did
have those powers
tries to consciously control all of his
automatic bodily processes nearly
suffocates
yeah uh yeah because he was like oh I
will think every time I breathe I feel
like this guy is sort of a dude who like
never stopped being sick like these are
the things that you do like before
someone's Tamp down on your imagination
and you're just like whoa my body does
stuff like can I make it do stuff
what hang on what's animal magnetism he
hears the animal magnetism is all the
rage learns it in secret it's illegal
magnetizes 80 people what is this yeah
this is basically like a version of
hypnotism right um and like putting
people in a trance and getting them to
do stuff uh which was yeah he went to
Vienna at the time and like yeah it was
illegal to do this uh
I need doing it to 80 people replaces
the blood of a silver gray rabbit with
the blood of a loppyed rabbit to see if
it can still breed it can tells himself
that everyone is spying on him to see if
he can make himself insane succeeds
makes a walking stick with a hidden
high-pitched whistle inside it takes it
to the zoo and whistles at all the
animals most don't care but the Lions
hate it yeah
yeah that's what science was like and
you know for the even the stuff that I
disagree with him something that I like
about him is that he has the spirit of
experimentation
um that like even if you are you know
the most established scientist in the
world like nobody does stuff like that
anymore and it's not because we have all
those things figured out uh like I think
there are still like kind of wackadoo
things that you could do to learn about
the world that people just kind of don't
do because they look too silly or like
oh well you can never write a paper
about that like you can't do arithmetic
by smell uh another thing he did early
on he was a like a trainee in um
basically a surgery like a doctor's
office and he just decided like I'm
gonna take a little bit of every
medicine alphabetically and so he just
goes down the list uh agility to this
thing called uh Croton oil
um and he has such bad diarrhea that he
um never does it ever again uh and he
stopped his alphabetical experiment but
this is a dude who's willing to you
screw around and find out
find everybody on the line
wow okay so rolling the clock forward he
then develops Eugenics which as soon as
you start to think about nature versus
nurture you realize that there are
certain things that you can perhaps
breed into or out of humans
um
why is it the case that somebody who is
incredibly smart and is able to come up
with a concept isn't able to foresee the
potential ethical implications of it is
this a a unique byproduct of eugenics
itself is eugenics particularly
ethically murky or is there something
else more broad going on
I think it's basically that he never
really had an opportunity to speak as
equals with someone who would be on the
losing side of a society based on
Eugenics
um so I mean you know for all his
scientific experimentation he's mainly
talking to other gentlemen of science
um who are all you know born into
wealthiest States like the reason they
can do this Victorian science is
basically because they inherited enough
money that they never had to work until
they could screw around all day
whistling at the lions at the zoo
um but if you had to talk to somebody
who was maybe bored into less wealth who
uh and you go like oh they don't seem
very fit because uh they they didn't
inherit all this wealth you might start
to realize like oh baby you know there's
more than just genes that determines
um your outcomes and maybe there's
something uh wrong about uh like
subsidizing Rich successful people to uh
to like marry each other and like
preventing uh poor less successful
people from marrying each other uh I
think basically just like no one was
around to call him on it um and to be
fair it's it's not just him like Decades
of by before anybody as far as I can
tell really write something mainstream
questioning the ethics of eugenics at
first it was all about well we don't
think it'll actually work I mean that
was the main thing that he was arguing
with uh with people because he's kind of
the first person to say that uh human
traits can be inherited
um and so a bunch of people like no they
can't or like oh you could never like
getting certain people to marry would
never do anything
and so this was purely a scientific
question uh of the people who are doing
science before someone enters a
conversation who's like hey guys this
seems like maybe a little bad
he was Darwin's cousin yeah like second
cousin yeah but like yeah they're
they're connected if you go back a few
Generations yeah I mean this Victorian
era say what you want man this Victorian
year I've read a ton of books about
Darwin seems so cool they've got these
weird rivalries this this particular guy
that they would both hate to see at
other conventions and everyone would
know about the the Rivalry between them
it's so fun I I really I don't know if
there has been a dramatized version of
Darwin's life I don't know how exciting
it would be to see a bunch of Stuffy
stiff upper lipped British guys just
saying mean words at each other across a
smoke-filled room but
I would watch it and I think that it's
pretty interesting I do Wonder
yeah it's very interesting to work out
why someone how someone could be so
smart is to come up with it and to not
see it moving forward I also remember
something in your article about
three generations of imbeciles is enough
and it was a landmark case in the US
yeah I think
yeah this is this is a case about uh
Force sterilization by the state
um or basically they decided that's fine
because I mean the reason he goes like
if you have enough stupid people in a
row according to the the metrics of the
state like well you've lost your like
right to continue reproducing and this
is the like very unfortunate place that
we get led to when we're like okay these
intelligence tests are everything that a
mind can do and like we should interfere
in uh and how people reproduce with one
another one another to like make us
better off
uh which are the unfortunate parts of
his legacy it can't all be you know
Alliance is there a precedent in the U.S
for forced sterilization that still
exists on the books
um I don't know whether it's still a law
or not but I do know as recently as the
2010s there were cases in California of
women you know always unclear when
you're in prison like to what extent are
you being told versus like pressured or
whatever but into getting tubal
ligations which is basically sterile
sterilized
um and so like this is going on pretty
recently
um and uh and I looked at some polling
so uh so another thing I study a lot is
changes in public opinion over time I
haven't seen recent polling on uh on
people's opinions on things like force
sterilization but even in the 90s
um uh people were saying like oh no that
kind of thing like sounds fine uh I mean
I want to go on the record like I don't
think it's fine I don't think the state
should be sterilizing people we
shouldn't put that power in the heads of
uh uh of the state it just yeah
um but yeah that kind of stuff is fairly
recent what do you think humans misjudge
when it comes to working out what other
people want to talk about in
conversation
uh so I have some studies where one of
the things that people were asked to
judge was
um when did the other person want to go
so I bring people into the lab they talk
as long as they want to and I asked them
like was there a point in which when you
wanted to go like tell me when that was
what about for the other person
um and what I find is people are really
bad at knowing when the other person
wanted to leave so when they guess
they're off by about half of the length
of the conversation so if we talk for 20
minutes and then I try to guess when you
want to go I'm off by about 10 minutes
in either direction
um people tend to underestimate a little
bit how much the other person wanted to
talk so it's not like we always think oh
all these people want to talk to me in
fact we're like a little bit
underconfident
but what this leads to is that
conversations generally don't end when
people want them to uh which is what
that paper is about so um so when we ask
people like okay your conversation went
on 25 minutes uh or 20 minutes when when
did you want it to end people tell us uh
the difference between when I wanted it
to end and when it ended was again about
half of the length of the conversation
so they want to go somewhere between 10
minutes or continue on for another 10
minutes uh and part of it because they
don't know when the other person wants
to go and the other part is people very
rarely want to speak for the same amount
of time I imagine this comes up a lot in
your line of work yeah it does some some
episodes some episodes seem to really be
rounded out quite nicely around about
the hour mark on average and then again
I'm the common denominator here so it's
probably me
um 110 to 115 for me is really really
nice and it's just finishing on a nice
Peak and it's maybe just starting to
drop off a tiny bit and you go bang
There It Is uh but then there's other
times when I can sit down with somebody
and I go all right this is I'm I'm not
even half not even getting going and
you've hit the hour numbers so there is
so much of a very interesting interplay
um rhythmically energetically in the way
that you speak to other people so that's
in terms of duration what about in terms
of content what do people mistake about
what others want to talk about
yeah there's some other research on this
that people just are bad at knowing
whether people like want to keep talking
about this topic or want to move on to
some other topic
um so it's not in like some particular
direction that like oh they want to talk
about football but I thought they want
to talk about basketball it's more just
like I really don't know what they want
to talk about some other research
suggests that people underestimate the
extent to which others want to have deep
conversations with them that you know we
get stuck having shallow conversations
um that how's the weather and oh that's
a nice shirt you're wearing uh thinking
that oh the other person doesn't want to
talk to me about like uh the problems
that they're having in their life right
now or the things that they're afraid of
or the things they're really excited
about because like oh I don't know
that's just kind of scary and
uncomfortable when in fact like no
people actually more willing than than
you think they are to have those kind of
conversations because I mean when we all
stand around being like Oh man isn't
small talk bad uh like we mean it like
we will really do want to actually have
deeper deeper conversations with people
I learned
I was reminded in your article about
that
series of 36 questions
it's a ascending scale of intensity that
yeah experiment is used to get people to
be friends what's that yeah yeah this is
the Fast Friends Paradigm and so there's
that big New York Times article about it
it's basically adapting those questions
to uh to be for
um uh to be more for friendship
so so the way that that works is what we
call um like increasing reciprocal
self-disclosure just basically the idea
of like I tell you a little bit more
about me I like open the door a little
bit you tell me a little more about you
you open your door a little bit and like
we go little by little until you know we
lower our guards and doors are open and
now we're willing to to chat we've got
chronic flatulence together uh yeah
exactly dude I've done some bad farts
recently uh yeah and you could get there
just 36 questions
one of my friends George sent me a
question the other day which I put in my
newsletter and I thought was absolutely
fantastic and you're the first person
that I've spoken to since he sent it to
me question was what is currently
overlooked or ignored by the media but
will be studied in future by historians
what do you think anything come to mind
yeah uh I would say the
professionalization of science
um that we had this idea that like
professionalization always good
um like making people professional that
sounds good and we don't realize that
that professionalizing something
actually makes a certain set of
trade-offs and basically you lower the
ceiling in order to raise the floor so
by professionalizing something you know
you Reign people in and so you prevent
the very best from doing exactly what
they do in order to prevent the very
worst from doing what they do in some
domains this makes total sense like I
want my doctor to be professionalized
because like I don't really care about
the very best doctor I mainly want a
Doctor Who's like good enough and isn't
going to harm me uh because sometimes
they put me under anesthesia and I don't
know what they're doing right it's
really hard for me to judge like which
are the good ones and which are the bad
ones I don't feel that way about
scientists I think science is what I
think of as a strong linked problem
where like we progress at the rate that
we make our most important discoveries
and do our most important work and so I
don't want to trade the best stuff in
order to get rid of the worst stuff I
think the worst stuff basically doesn't
matter uh it just fills journals nobody
ever looks at it ever again uh and it's
like very weird that we live in this
period where science is super
professionalized and we're mainly
focused on like how do we stop like the
these random bad study from coming out
that no one's ever going to look at
again uh if you think about Golden's
time like there wasn't the
standardization like I mean the dude was
wandering around like swapping blood
from one rabbit to another and nobody
was like stopping him from doing it uh
what was that what was that thing where
wasn't he tutored by his sister who had
some bad spine problems so she had to
lie on a plank of wood
the weirdest life ever yeah yeah uh yeah
I mean this isn't to mention like all
the the travels that he did in southern
Africa where uh earlier all over the
world we're constantly running into
um uh quarantines uh because there's
pandemics going on and so reading this
like I read that mainly uh you know a
year and a half ago when there's a lot
more that's going on and being like whoa
like so little has J or like we're back
at this moment
um where and a lot of it too is like
this theatrical element of like I showed
up at this place and like because I was
kind of prominent I was invited to like
dine with the mayor of the town but then
the newspapers were like mayor of town
breaks quarantine to talk to like man
this is all just wow yes yeah Dear God
what um you you looked at some stuff to
do with why we forget so many of the
topics and bits and pieces that we learn
what what's the 30 000 foot view on that
for someone that's not been
indoctrinated
yeah this is just the idea of like you
spend a lot of time in school learning a
lot of stuff and like pretty quickly you
remember almost none of that stuff uh so
like what's kind of what's that all for
like what are we doing here and I mean
there's a question of like okay well
what are the like Educators intend to do
but I think there's a different question
of like what is the mind doing
um which is I think not holding on very
tightly to any individual fact but
getting some abstract sense of the way
that things are which I call a Vibe
basically and these things actually
stick for a long time maybe forever and
so the important things that you're
learning in class aren't necessarily
like what Mesopotamia was or like how
many like the US representatives there
are it is a sense of like oh history is
interesting or like history is
complicated or history is very long or
like there are many ways that humans can
organize themselves into different
societies and like the way that things
are now is not the way that they've
always been and they can be other ways
um uh and these are like the kind of
like deep truths that no no one ever
really tells you specifically but like
you are learning them by sitting there
you can get other Vibes too like
education is stupid and like it's just a
matter of satisfying the whims of the
teacher
um uh or like you know it's cool like uh
like this sucks I want to be anywhere
else like these are Vibes too and I
think these are actually the more
important things that we get when we are
in education rather than like all the
PowerPoint bullet point stuff that we're
going to forget as soon as the test is
done and so so I mean I am partly an
educator and so I think a lot about like
what is the thing that people are
getting like when I speak like when I
write like the important stuff isn't uh
like this thing buried in this paragraph
like it is basically an approach to life
like it is a it is a philosophy that's
kind of hard to put in any one place but
that you get this emergent property from
spending a lot of time in it what would
be a more direct way for people to learn
vibes
the kind of the thing is like you can't
get there direct like that's the whole
point is like you can't hack The Vibes
um I think you can do a better job as an
educator of thinking about like what
Vibes am I giving and thinking about
like oh the most important thing isn't
that they remember what ancient Sumer is
it is that they like remember that like
human history is very long and
complicated and like sometimes people do
really good things and sometimes people
do really bad things we're capable of
all sorts of things none of those things
are going to be like the lesson of the
day uh like they're gonna be the thing
that like kind of sticks on your mind's
ribs when you leave
um so yeah I kind of think it can't be
sped up uh it can only be appreciated
it's a little bit like what we were
saying earlier on to do with
a lot of people have to go through the
success in order to be able to say that
success isn't the thing that was going
to make them happy that's a lesson that
can't really be expedited in advance and
uh I wonder whether
I don't know maybe it is just the case
that you need to sit down and bang your
head off the wall about the four
principles of whatever is appropriate
accounting I remember dude I remember in
first year of uni and I lived in this
set of Halls of residence that was two
and a half miles away from the
University so we had to get a bus in got
to get a bus to nights out we had to get
a bus to lectures and it was the morning
of this the morning of this exam and my
housemate who was a big stiff idiot but
was a lovely guy hadn't done any
revision and he said what do you think's
coming up on the examiner so I think
it's going to be the four the four
principles of accounting or something
like that
I can remember the conversation I had
with him I can remember thinking wow I I
actually did even my lackadaisical
version of of revision makes me feel
like super smart compared to you and I
remember that one of them is prudence
can't remember any any of the others I
don't really even know what Prudence
means when it comes to accounting yeah I
mean you're accounting for the figures
what are you being prudent about the
figure's either there or it's not I have
no idea how it wraps in and this is what
16 years ago now probably yeah 15 or 16
years ago and I have no idea about the
rest of it yeah but I do remember what
it feels like to have a sense of guilt
around your lack of preparation and
realize that there is way deeper to fall
because there is always somebody who is
less prepared than you yeah yeah and
like if your professor had stood up and
said like there's further like there's
always someone lower than you like that
too would go the way of prudence it
wouldn't make any sense yes yes
interesting you had to experience that I
mean to your point like I did a master's
degree at Oxford which I remember none
of any of the stupid pointless lectures
that they had what like the thing that I
remember from there is living in this
terrible apartment and I was one day in
the basement kitchen like eating
Weetabix in the morning and uh it was
like toward the end of the year so they
were bringing people in to like look at
the apartment and so the students came
down the stairs and like I'm there in
like my t-shirt and like my boxers or
whatever eating my cereal and one of
them looks around at this kitchen that's
like not well lit it's dank it's bad and
it's like I could never live here I'd
kill myself and then I left I'm like
well like was the uh symbolic lesson
that you took away from that
um I was like uh I think it's like man
you could be at what some people
consider the best university in the
world and people could walk into the
intimate parts of your life and say that
if they experience those things they
would kill themselves so like think
about like whether all this legible
stuff matters a lot or whether I want to
be living in such a way little people
walk into the room they go oh I'd like
to do that too wow so it what it ties
into really nicely and is a concept I
learned from Tim Ferriss called the good
[__] sticks and you talk about this as
well that the stuff that really
resonates with you that lights a fire
inside of you that feels uh
existentially important in some way you
don't need to have a Anki space
repetition ebbing house forgetting curve
hack for this you're gonna not gonna
you're going to be in unable to stop
thinking about it yeah that's how
important it's going to be to you and
you know as somebody that has crushing
volumes of high pressure content on a
daily basis
that's absolutely the best way to do it
for me now that could be a cope right
because if I had a better personal
Knowledge Management System with an
externalized second brain and my notes
were all organized I would definitely be
able to recall more but certainly if
you're not someone who is geared in that
sort of a way and if you are you'll
already know you'll already be the kind
of person that's probably got a
perfectly designed notion database with
all of your lessons tagged properly and
whatever whatever and this isn't right
if you're a med student I understand you
actually need to know what all of the
terms mean like that's why angry was
created for those sorts of people but
for the most part if it's just you're a
curious individual that wants to pick up
stuff I wouldn't stress yourself over oh
God I'm so stupid I can't remember
things I can't recall things my recall
dude for so long especially toward the
end of my 20s probably because I partied
a lot during my 20s I think I was
suffering with some sort of acute brain
atrophy was so embarrassing I used to I
used to hate it because I'd look up to
these Mammoth Titans of recall in the
world of philosophy or personal
development or productivity and they'd
just be bing bing bing all of these
studies would come off and it would
sound so perfect and flowy and it just
took a good bit of time for me to
realize you you need crushing volumes of
content in order to be able to retain
even a modicum of something that can
hold half a conversation with somebody
hmm yeah uh I think there's this General
tendency toward thinking you can
optimize your life in such ways that
like I just need the right systems and
like then I'll remember the right stuff
which like there are things on the
margins like yeah I don't know you
should like a calendar is helpful like
some kind of way of dealing with email
is helpful
um but but like take that philosophy too
far uh and this is a piece that I've
been working on like you end up being
the person who like you've optimized
everything and you're miserable
um like there are things that you just
can't optimize because they're like
mysterious or you have to experience
them
um the like uh I think about when when
people like go through a terrible
breakup and you're like you know you
will like don't worry you'll feel better
uh like there isn't really like a series
of things that you can do to like make
the feeling better happen faster like
you just gotta live the day and then the
day after and then like it happens as if
by Magic but it eventually does happen
there is no way of speeding it up uh and
the more you try to speed it up the more
you slow it down uh and so like this
this like tendency toward optimization I
think is like helpful when kind of
corralled rather than like the the
feeling of your life thinking about this
new Venture that you've been going
through for the last couple of years
writing your sub stack what are you
doing you're sitting down you know that
you need to write something because it's
been however many days and you've got a
deadline that you've set yourself
totally arbitrarily yeah what are you
doing that you found is an effective way
to get past writer's block and creative
creative sort of blocks yeah I do a few
things one is whenever I feel stuck like
I can get the sentence right I can't get
this point right I ask myself like what
would be the like what is the most
honest thing that I want to say right
now like if I faced no consequences for
what I was gonna say like what would I
say and often I find that like the
reason that uh I I can't write this is
because I'm like I like feel like I
shouldn't say it or I shouldn't say it
this way
um so sometimes it'll come out sometimes
I'll be like oh I actually don't know
enough about this yet that is what
because what I would say is I don't know
or like nah I'm kind of like glossing
over some stuff here and so then I go
back and uh and research more another
thing is it is like I try to give myself
too much time that like these things
take time to bake uh and it's like you
can't bake cookies Faster by like
cranking them up to 4 000 degrees and
like cooking them in a sec I mean there
are like machines that are meant to do
that right but like you can't do that in
your oven like they just take the time
to bake that it takes and I feel the
same way when I'm like baking an idea
for experimental history that like if I
try to speed it up I'm just gonna burn
it and like it's gonna taste bad I'm not
gonna like it uh and so I have to give
myself the amount of time that it takes
and if I'm not done in time then I'm
just not done in time
um because I'd rather give people
something that they'd like to read than
like the like an email that they that I
think they should receive
if I try to complete it too quickly then
I'm going to burn the idea and it's not
going to taste good I really really like
that I really like it and um yeah it's a
very strange especially for me right
because podcasting is a medium I always
have a aspiring partner except for maybe
one episode in 30 I do on my own but for
the most part it's me and and somebody
else so my my motivation is externalized
my preparation yeah so like you know I
get to read all the stuff that you do I
don't have to generate I have to
generate nothing right apart from Half
Baked takes about stuff from 15 years
ago that I can't even remember on a bus
to you yeah so it's a very different
sort of medium but I've I have started
writing more and more frequently at the
moment
and it is one hell of a battle at times
yeah to sit down and to get things out
and I do um
for the guys that are full-time writers
that are cranking out thousands and
thousands of words a week I mean do you
know Brandon Sanderson have you heard of
him no no he's a Fantasy author there's
a really cool post on Reddit which any
sentence that begins with there's a
really cool post on Reddit is followed
up by a sentence which is nothing cool
at all but yeah really cool post on
Reddit and it explains the number of
words or pages per year that this guy
outputs compared with the other most
prolific page writers within the fantasy
genre fantasy being known as a genre
which can be a bit verbose right it can
it can be padded out quite nicely I
remember once in uh the name of the win
by Patrick rothfuss he spends like two
full chapters explaining this kid's walk
to work where he goes to play his like
loot or something and he's describing in
like intense detail the type of
cobblestones he walks over anyway
um this guy is five times as prolific as
the next biggest fantasy author in terms
of output and he's he's got Secret
Series that he just hasn't ever got
around to releasing and then he'll just
pull the pin and they just appear on
Amazon and they're all really really
good or at least most of them are good
the ones I've listened to so yeah when I
look at people like that and realize how
challenging and incompetent I find
sitting down to right yeah it does feel
like a very different sort of very
different world
yeah and uh and I think part of this
figuring like okay what's the niche that
you're good at like some people are like
crankers and they just like they're like
a fire hose of content
um and like that's good uh like I want
to be I don't know what's it uh rather
than a fire hose of content like like a
bunch of water balloons like I want them
to go off uh I don't want to be like oh
man I'm soaked but in a good way I guess
and then like I'll be like I'll see you
in two weeks like I'll throw another one
at you uh and like I want what I write
to be something that people look forward
to rather than like oh it's always the
hum in the background like I'm never
gonna out BuzzFeed BuzzFeed I'm never
gonna be better than cable news at like
filling time like my comparative
advantage is like baking things until
they are to me like perfectly baked or
as close as I can get and then putting
them out into the world yes it's I mean
it's a good measure of
how excited people are to read your
stuff or to watch your listen or
whatever which is how many people open
the email yeah how many how many people
when you send out that newsletter or
whatever it is on a Monday morning how
many people actually open it and yeah uh
yeah that's a really nice heuristic you
just want people to be excited about
your work you don't want people to feel
obliged to read it oh I've better I'd
better read Adam's next piece of work
my boss is going to shout at me if I
don't and you don't need to be laborious
yeah that's a very very nice heuristic
and I love the idea of allowing
something to bake until it's done
because if you do Russian it's just not
going to taste as good and also when it
comes to the stuff that we do ourselves
it is for the most part the deadlines
are arbitrary I think it's important to
you know create some constraints or else
you're just going to Parkinson's lure
yourself into a one article lifetime
which is yeah you know maybe not totally
great however
most of the deadlines especially the
things that we learned from school
probably don't Port across that well
especially when the difference between
your work being
really really nicely done and being
unnecessarily rushed could be a lot that
being said I think that this is a mature
Creator problem rather than an immature
Creator problem when you're more on the
immature side you just need to iterate
right until you've done whatever 200
repetitions at the thing that you're
trying to do I just get it out you know
if it is it is it is it 95 is it 65 it
kind of doesn't matter no one's reading
it anyway so yeah I think early on focus
more on the sort of explore and then on
the back end you can learn to bake a bit
better yeah yeah but part of that same
mindset comes from uh so I I teach and
perform improv comedy as well and like
yeah what you do early on in class is
like you do a lot of terrible scenes uh
like nobody sees them until later
um but then later you get the sense of
like or I always have the sense anyway
that like why would people come and sit
and watch something that I'm making up
in front of them like it better be worth
their time because like they could be at
home like eating Pringles and watching
like any movie humankind has ever made
like any TV it's all at their fingertips
there's a lot of good stuff that you
could do so like why should they come
here uh and like I do actually think
there's good answers to that question
like there is something that can happen
in a room that like cannot happen in
your living room like there's a moment
that we can create like when we're on
stage and actually it's much better
being there when it's good
um than uh than you know re-watching
Breaking Bad uh and I feel the same way
about writing that like yeah why would
people write read my stuff rather than
you know you could read anything that
any human's ever created I'm like well
it's because like only I could write
this thing because it's like it required
me to have all these experiences there
was no a way of speeding up the
production of this article like I had to
live for 31 years and like think of your
thoughts and put it out and I do think
like this is better than other stuff
that you can read
um and like I'm just foolish enough to
think that uh that's the problem and
this is a piece of advice I gave in a
tedx talk two and a bit years ago now uh
if you try to be your version of
somebody else if you mimic a copy too
much from some other Creator the very
best that you can hope for is being the
second best them in the world yeah if I
if I want to be Joe Rogan at best I can
be the second best Joe Rogan on the
planet which you know is not necessarily
that bad of a position given how
successful he's been but it's nowhere
near as good as being the first best you
and yeah you can actually be the second
best you to somebody else if you're not
careful like you can you can uh mitigate
and dilute down the essence of the work
that you do because you're trying to
adhere to some arbitrary set of rules
that you've decided you need to follow
uh
on a similar Point talking about why the
general public is so stupid
seems to be very trendy and this is
something that I've noticed super super
trendy to discuss about how societies
going down the toilet and everybody is
just an idiot why do you think that is
so popular
yeah part of it is uh you know it makes
it makes you look smart when you call
other people stupid like there's been
some psychology research on this at
least if people think that this is the
case
um another thing so I didn't write that
in in that piece but part of my
dissertation work was on people's
perceptions that people are less good
than they used to be like less kind less
honest less nice and and then actually I
went and tried and like tried to find
any evidence that this has been changing
over time like and there's no obvious
like objective measure of people's
goodness and I mean like everyday inner
personal things I don't mean like did
you murder somebody yesterday uh but all
these surveys like how often do you
encounter incivility at work like uh do
people treat you with respect all day
yesterday like did you do this nice
thing how about that nice thing all
these things are flat over time for as
long as we've measured them but people
think that they go down down all these
different ones uh and I think that comes
from two phenomena one is
um when you look out on the world will
you read the news it's mainly about
people being bad and dumb uh like that's
what makes headlines uh is like this
person killed that person and like this
person embezzled some money and so every
day you look out in the world and like
it looks bad if you look at it that way
but there's a phenomenon uh in the
memory literature called The Fading
affect bias which is just basically the
Badness of bad stuff Fades faster than
the goodness of good stuff and you can
run this study on yourself that like you
know if you remember things that
happened to you when you're 18 like the
bad things now probably don't feel so
bad unless they were like really
terrible and the good things like still
feel pretty good uh so something like oh
I got turned down for prom like now it's
like oh man isn't that funny like being
a teenager right and the good stuff that
like oh man I had a really great problem
like still feels kind of good and this
is true on average for how people's
memories work over time and so if you
put that together with the fact that
like every day it looks like people in
general are bad but there's this memory
bias where like it kind of seems like
there was less bad in the past you can
get this illusion of a decline and you
can get it for things like morality you
can get it for competence intelligence
um but it's all illusory because like
these things are actually really hard to
measure over time and anyone who's like
I definitely know how it's changed is
like fooling themselves what is the
reason for this asymmetry between how
sane we feel we are and how insane
everybody else feels I had this
discussion last night it always keeps on
coming up this weird imbalance between
what we see ourselves and what we see of
everyone else and often I think we
believe that we see the world in a sane
way and everybody else yes is very very
odd yes there's this thing called naive
realism which is just the idea that like
my eyes are little portholes out of
which I see the world and I'm just
seeing it how it is like there's no
interpretive step after that the
information gets to my brain and up to
my Consciousness like that's just what
it is when in fact there's all kinds of
interpretive steps I mean even basic
sensory perceptive stuff that like the
world that you see isn't actually the
world that's out there like your eyes
and your visual cortex make it useful
for you um but that also happens with
higher level stuff like the ideas that
you hear that when you hear them you're
like oh no bad idea oh no good idea like
all that's pre-processing that's done
under the hood like you didn't
consciously arrive at that decision but
feels like that's just the way that it
is so when you look at other people who
perceive the world in a different way it
just seems like they're mistaken and
when you're like oh no actually dude
it's a it's this way and they're like no
it's not you're like oh you're dumb
because like this is obviously this is
the way the world is and if you disagree
like you just must be like something's
wrong in your head
um so I think I think that is part of it
uh another part of why we feel this way
about people we don't know very well but
like when you're closer to someone you
can give them more leeway they're like I
know why you see the world differently
from me because I know you all these
complicated differences in experience
this is why like we cut our friends a
lot of slack but when you don't know
someone you're just like yeah you're
just a dumb person and this phenomenon
of psychological distance that like the
closer you are to something the more
detail in which you perceive it and the
more detail that you perceive someone I
think the more slack you give them but
if someone's just kind of like this blur
to you this blob then you're like no
there's no complication to people in
general they're not a bunch of you know
flawed humans doing the best they can
there are a bunch of like idiots and
evil people
um and when we get closer and closer
like when you those people become your
friends like no actually not this one
but all the other ones are uh so there's
an illusion that keeps getting pushed
back I wouldn't do but well I can see
how that might be adaptive for us to
have that that the people that you're
closest to you need to kick off at the
least frequently you need to not find a
problem with every single thing that
they say whereas if it's somebody else
maybe from let's say a different family
within your tribe or from even a
different tribe you can afford to judge
them much more quickly because the risk
of not doing so would be quite grave if
this is the Smoking Gun that this
person's a malevolent narcissist you
want to be able to figure it out pretty
quickly but if you have this broader
sample of behavior maybe you can give
them a little bit more room yeah you
can't think hard about everything like
you can't uh like go through a
deliberative process about everything
that comes to mind like you have to be
very uh selective about that so it makes
sense that like the people closest to
you get the most detail about them um
because we have to deal with them the
most and the people farthest from you
get blurrier and blurrier I mean it
works the same thing the way in your
visual field like the things that you
pay Point your eyes directly at have the
most detail and it's hard to tell but
the further and further out you get in
your visual field like eventually your
color vision goes away like all of that
is just abstract none of it feels that
way you have to look at like visual
illusions that make this clear
um uh but it's the same thing like you
like the whole the whole part of your
visual field cannot be the point that's
most in Focus like you have to be
selective well I think the same thing
works in mind correspondence bias
this is the idea that that other
people's behavior flows from their
personality rather than their situation
um so you see somebody who's ticked off
and you go it's because they're a mad
person not because they're in a mad
situation or a situation that made them
angry
um and there's there's this kind of
other part that Alvin Islam did this
Actor Observer Bias that we do this more
for other people than for us because you
perceive yourself in the most detail so
I know all the stuff about like my
mitigating circumstances and why I do
what I do and I go oh well I was pushed
this way and that way
um like that's why I did it it's not
because it flowed from my uh like the
person that I am since yes exactly uh
and so I told this story in the in this
post of like the first time I got to New
York where you know I'm walking through
LaGuardia I'm like looking for a taxi
and a woman comes up and she's like hey
do you need a taxi I'm like I sure do
like thanks kind New Yorker like people
were wrong about people in this town
look at all these friendly people
anticipating my needs and she's like
come with me and we walk outside and
then we walk across the street into a
parking garage and I'm like this doesn't
this isn't where I expected the taxi to
be and then we get to an unmarked car
I'm like usually taxis are yellow and
she's like get in and I'm like oh I feel
like I'm in a bad situation but I don't
want to be impolite I came all this way
and I did say that I would go with her
and she's like okay you can sit in the
passenger seat I'm like uh all right and
so I had this planned like if she tries
to kidnap me I'll just grab the wheel
and I'll steer us into a building and
then she'll be dazed because she's in
the middle age and I'm 18 and I'll Dash
from the car and I'll get my luggage out
of the back and then I'll run away and
like all those that story might make me
sound like I'm a stupid person but each
of those things felt like I'm in this
kind of weird situation like I don't
want to harm this person like I don't
want to be mean
um and like each individual's decision
that I make doesn't seem that stupid
um but it yeah but when because I'm in
that situation I'm like I know
everything that went into it
that's similar to is it the fundamental
attribution error or it might even be
the same thing by different different
word for the same thing yeah yes I
thought so there was a period in the
world of product about four to six years
ago a guy called Shane Parish blog
called fs.blog Farnham Street and he
wrote a book of great mental models to
think by and and it did very very well
and he's a super super smart guy and
he's been on the show
the rationalist movement as well that
Scott Alexander and ellioto yukowski
were a big part of lesserong.com then
turned into slate star codex the
national codex 10 all this stuff which
you'll be familiar with
there was a period in my life and I
think most people's lives that have come
up through that corner of the internet
where I thought if I just know the name
of every cognitive bias if I've just
brute forced myself to wrote memorize
every single one of the cognitive bias
list on Wikipedia
I will transcend Humanity yeah become an
awakened being
why is it not the case I think is it is
the same problem of trying to optimize
your life in ways it can't actually be
optimized so like if we go back to you
know you go through a terrible breakup
and you're like oh actually uh I'm doing
bad affective forecasting like I think
that my uh my emotions will continue
longer than they actually do and now I
Ascend into the realm of the person who
like isn't affected by it's like knowing
how the thing works doesn't mean you can
just open it up and change it uh like
our my mind's like they don't have a
hood that you can pop open and like fix
the carburetor uh so some of these
things like yeah it does help like okay
I know what sunk cost fallacy is and now
I know better to spot it and like I
don't do it as much anymore
um but some of these things like there
isn't a way around it uh and in fact
like thinking that you can get around it
it keeps you stuck in it longer because
now you're thinking like why haven't my
bad feelings gone away I mispredict how
long they're going to uh yeah and so I
think when you look at these
rationalists which like I'm very
adjacent to that part of the internet I
think like look around like do they seem
happy like they they seem like very
stressed out and anxious all the time
because they're just trying to think
correctly well I suppose the other thing
that you layer on top and this is one of
the curses of knowledge is that you
actually can layer on shame if you're
not careful because now not only did you
succumb to your fundamental attribution
error or whatever you multiplied by zero
accidentally uh but now you have to
shame around the fact that you do this
bias before you did it and you still did
it so now you feel like yeah like in a
self-imposed idiot as opposed to just an
idiot that circumstance circumstantial
yeah why can't I make my brain work
right like I'm thinking all the right
thoughts like why don't they work
yes yeah dude it's a it's a real um I
feel that's another thing that people
just need to go through you know if
you're if you're 20 and listening to
this and thinking I'm gonna check out
fs.blog please do it's a fantastic
repository of all of these different
cognitive biases enjoy the next three
years yeah of learning them and and
creating Anki uh note cards to be able
to try and do your ebbing house
forgetting curve and then when you're 26
or 27 you can say God I'm glad that I
went through that I don't remember any
of it and but you will remember the vibe
you'll remember the fact that yeah we
are less rational than we think we are
we do not know how rational we can be
and cognitive biases are not fixed by
learning cognitive biases
yeah uh I wonder what's that for us
right now like dude I think the future
the time I think this all the time
you've stepped into you've hit one of my
traps uh which is what am I going to
look back on in five years time and
think you knew this 10 years ago why
weren't you stopping doing this five
years ago
yeah I sometimes think that like there's
really only seven things to learn in
life but you can only remember one at a
time and just life is the process of
forgetting one and remembering another
um and I wish I could tell you what they
were but I could only remember why
yeah oh God I mean if you ever look back
at the things where you say what would
you have what do you wish that you 10
years ago would have known
that's pretty good advice for how you're
behaving right now when I write that out
for myself I think yeah
right now Chris needs to listen to this
as well that's not that's not that's not
advice for him forever ago because we
are
we were cursed or blessed to repeat the
same patterns over and over again and I
suppose
you know you've filtered restricted by I
know that this is a problem but am I
going to act on it am I nervous about
acting on it do I feel stupid because
does this feel comfortable to me somehow
does this type of trauma or difficulty
somehow feel familiar in a way that's
actually going to keep me stuck in it
even more uh yeah it's um
it's very very interesting looking at
the progress of personal knowledge
development over time dude Adam I I
really really love your work everyone
needs to go and check out your sub stack
where should they go where can they
follow you and harass you on the
internet uh experimental
history.substack.com
um and you can shout at me there and I
will hear you dude I appreciate you
thank you thanks for having me it was
great fun what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face
[Music]